comment allez-vous moi ça va extrêmement
bien à part quelques heures du matin et
que j'ai la voix du matin comme s'il
était 6 heures un problème de youtube
heures quelle insolence
aujourd'hui on va jouer un jeu vidéo qui
est tout simplement excellent que
j'apprécie grandement il s'appelle cup
est vous avez tous entendu parler de ce
jeu parce que plein de médias en ont
parlé en disant qu'ils étaient
incroyables à juste titre ou alors vous
avez vu le fameux gameplay de
journalistes qui restent coincés dans le
tuto pendant je sais pas combien de
minutes
[Musique]
oh c'était horrible ce moment était
tellement terrible petit brief rapide
c'est un jeu de plateforme qui s'inspire
des dessins animés des années 30 donc
c'est extrêmement cool c'est non non ce
qu'on adore vous avez tous vu des
extraits du premier épisode de mickey
jamais créé ben c'est dans ce délire là
et on va pas ce mytho c'est un jeu où il
faut un petit qu'il aime beaucoup de ski
vilain un peu rageant bref j'ai lancé je
la dernière fois en live parce que
j'avais envie de jouer tout le monde en
parle je me disais plus tard et ça doit
quand même être ouf
eh ben c'est où et aujourd'hui je suis
une vidéo dessus parce que mon pachuca
35% du jeu il nous reste des bosses à
faire alors on va y aller tout de suite
ont juste un trauma donner chaud mais
j'imagine pas quand j'ai commencé à
jouer à rage est bien sévère à l'est la
musique aussi s'est basé sur les années
30 c'est du bon jazz bien cool et alors
faut savoir qu'il ya deux types de
niveau il ya les niveaux auxerre boss
qui a plusieurs phases de dire qu'il va
falloir analyser ces mouvements
s'adapter en fonction et ce à chaque
nouvelle phase ok donc là on a un niveau
c'est pas un boss et un niveau normal on
va se mettre en regular je mettrai pas
la difficulté en simple je fais la vraie
difficulté parce qu'on était bonhomme
c'est bien ça fait un moment que j'ai
pas joué ça me remettre dans le bain
c'est un beau je me suis trompé je le
cite ropert ah ok fonctionne sur un
nuage et faut que j'estime à bex la
première guerre qu'elle vous voyez je
fais les gars qu'est ce qu'il fait à ses
nouveaux ce voyez il envoie différents
sens et quand tu découvres le diable à
coeur donc ici à chaque petit piqué qui
précède le drapeau ça signifie que ces
nouvelles phases que le boss va utiliser
de nouvelles compétences pour nous
démolir la gueule
auger chaud chaud j'ai fini la vidéo
alors donc là on a vu qu'ils envoient
une bouille l'envoi des anneaux ça c'est
la phase la plus simple de l'histoire du
jeu et ensuite ils envoient une boule
lie à la boule gala que en bas faut
faire attention à deux choses en même
temps c'est ça qui est dur et en plus je
vous parle en même temps aux deux
boucles plus tard il imite les hommes
c'est incroyable et non blague
abonnez vous ah j'oubliais un détail
important on a trois vies bar niveau
entier donc là on a nos trois vies
logique mois pour survivre faut qu'on
atteigne la dernière phase avec deux vie
minimum voilà c'est un peu la règle d'or
je me suis fait avoir c'est bon ok ok
nouvelle phase au [ __ ] c'est quoi ça
ils vont faire quoi ils vont faire de la
merde il y en a qui saute de manière
aléatoire à chaque fois bon ok on
analyse et on va y arriver vous en
faites pas ah [ __ ]
première phase passée il nous reste deux
visages face caf
ok je les ai vus
très peu de temps pour réagir on
m'appelle je vous annonce un jérémy roy
la face dame de fer
hélas aucun set face à des dacquois ya
la queue aux caisses et mon dernière
fosse où elle a trois
raté raté je suis prêt entre la boule et
là que quad et raffinement non mais
vraiment il anticipe montceau mec c'est
normal ça j'ai envie de manger ma main
c'est bon pour la troisième fois est ce
qu'on va dire oui lance des flammes ait
un dragon ça mc dowell roland des
flammes aussitôt non mes mecs c'est
chiant je fais super match et changer de
chaise l'accoudoir est très fort je me
suis basé
le mec saut dans le vide mais quel
connard aulas
ok cette fois je me disais mon héros
boire pour cette femme regarde bien
c'est parti tout va bien
j'arrive pas à prévoir les flammes quand
ils sont assis elle fut tel mail avant
de sauter je suis qu il a sauté la
police m'a pas empêché de me l'apprendre
c'est moche c'est maintenant office de
piste où tu meurs meurs meurs mais on
adore
assez sa voiture fait ça il sait bien
comment lancer sans prévenir j'ai
regardé ya rien qui indique
[Musique]
ok c'est soit faire alors on va changer
de pouvoir mettre celui-là c'est une
sorte de fusils à pompe et maintenant on
va passer ce niveau en musique je saute
de nuages en nuage et vip l'épaule jaune
or avec prudence la suite coûte que puis
j'ai pas vu
je me suis clairement délavé gens
comment sans me lasser way face aux
blues
majesty l'écheveau des pages web plus
[ __ ] tu vas voter
[Musique]
et seulement
il
la gamme
sauvé un jeune blanc dresse au monde
d
le but de raccroc la bagarre je crois
que je peux la vraie bande joie là pour
moi c'est ça le jeu vidéo c'est quand
c'est super dur mais quand tu réussit un
sentiment que c'était vraiment heureux
quoi c'est là je suis dans un état
psychologique de détresse je me confie
faut savoir qu'à 12h30 je dois manger
avec mon père mais j'étais bloqué sur ce
boss faut que j'étais en train de
culpabiliser vous allez mon papa me
disant je mérite en retard au [ __ ]
folle à millau puis on a eu des mois on
est une super maintenant je veux comment
le mat est dans du bronze et qu'on leur
foute allait repartir du boulot comme
ronaldo allait s'il vous plaît alors
alors musée 2 alors je vous explique ce
que c'est celle jav
il faut aider la personne qui est dedans
en la protégeant des fantômes donc faut
tuer tous les fantômes et j'ai oublié
dire mais tous queiroz danger en fait ça
se tue en sautant et en éclats quand
voilà non ok [ __ ] sondeurs tout genre
que la crfs pièce la double voie là là
mais là on échoue à la lame est
tellement aisément et là du coup on a
sauvé la personne qui était dans la
jarre et qu'il fallait protéger et qui
est si jolie demoiselle c'est une coupe
à on a débloqué un nouveau super
pouvoirs ckoi invicibilité devient ainsi
pour une courte période mais je suis
trop con mais c'est ce pouvoir là qu'il
fallait utiliser sur le dragon pour la
dernière phase c'est pour ça que j'ai
galéré je me disais bien c'est risqué ce
que je faisais je risque est de tomber
dans le vide après l'avoir fait oh le
con alors alors on va finir cette zone
ensemble moi je vous le dire oh mais
c'est un petit niveau pépère mais
doucement va céder bosse au niveau ppr
ont l'effet pekouz au il est super dur
suis là j'ai une histoire de gravité mon
pote tu regardes ça voilà les voitures
elles me démonte on va y arriver on y
arrive et c'est pas hyper dur ah ok ça
waouh je crois pas j'ai un bon prix en
fait que rim c'est quand appuyé sur le
bouton ça change pas immédiatement un
gars il ya un petit temps ça le piège en
fait une pièce de la thune alors ça
c'est quoi faut tirer je crois au ch
non quelle erreur peut mentir c'est
assez dur de jonah lomu jumeaux europe
tabarnak je sais qu'il faut que je fasse
tout change dans le temps une heure j'ai
fait qu'un boss make you tandis que la
durée de vie de ce jeu est assez où il
est mort il est des dalles et on lui
passe dans la bouche suivant au [ __ ]
c'est quoi ça c'est quoi ça ces partis
speed run sans jamais s'arrêter si la
technique aux houches j'ai pas vu je
comprends pas je cherche c'est une
nouvelle partie niveau que j'ai pas
encore fait ah ouais d'accord ok j'ai
compris fallait que je passe quand on
écrit non des lignes droites sont
permanents je chiale je suis quoi je
faut que juste que je passe pas d'
arnaque s'il vous plaît attends je crois
l'avoir compris
voilà on est bien mais qu'est ce qui
nous reste à faire et voilà le dernier
niveau que je n'ai pas fait on est bon
au sein vote
oh [ __ ] alors c'est quoi ce poste
qu'est ce qu'il fait ok ils envoient des
bombes ont assez que des moments a donc
à une certain move à avoir ok c'est ça
faut que je fasse que je fais là ok ok
ok ok mais une fois que j'ai eu
analysons les phases à l era jauger
pétition va faire quoi
qu'est ce qu'il ya ok j'ai fait de la
merde la map a l'air assez serré je
ferais mieux de prendre larmes du japon
watts mais ça a changé c'est pas le même
que tout à l'heure
all bat suivant ok donc là c'est le truc
qui volent c'est comme ce qu'on a fait
avant c'est faux ces fonds ils se
disloque
moi quand j'ai fait ça fait trop chaud à
merde bon alors il a pas d hyper dur ce
boss avec le careï va nous péter schep
pas pourquoi je fais ça à chaque fois à
wahaha c'est encore un nouveau bon
[ __ ] mais ça change tout le temps et
je tiens ils envoient des billes dans
mais lui il est trop dure et ckoi
apprend comment sais tu recommences quoi
il est trop près sur quoi on va prendre
ça et on est bon c'est parti est-ce
qu'elle renvoie les mêmes
ouais c'est ça c'est les mêmes à chaque
fois qu on voit le fusil à pompe c'est
tellement puissant on va pas sculpté on
va rester sur un fusil à pompe basée à
benton autres sucreries et un push
encore aller deuxième sucreries battu
suivante annoncé la flaque lagarde parce
qu'il fait une sorte d'art oui en fait
quand il tape le sol voyez rajouter trop
chaud alors c'est quoi ensuite la phase
d'après auquel raja le tir ciblé cheveux
de ses amis au [ __ ] sait pas où a pu
tin oo tabarnak hockey lâchant que c'est
quoi ça oh [ __ ]
oh [ __ ] [ __ ] j'ai horreur des trucs
qui reste aux yeux c'est trop chaud à ce
truc est chiant avec les chiots on a
survécu 15 secondes et regardez on en
n'est pas pour d'impôts que je pense
qu'on va en chier
[Musique]
ok chocolat ok ça ne dégage la voie des
dragibus de merde
ces photos ne pas vider irish qui fait
rage parmi ces le plusieurs noms que je
dis ça le karma attention 3,2 à mais je
suis qu'une vie sa mort
des super dur papa tu as peut-être mangé
sans moi [ __ ] souvenez-vous du
sentiment qu'on aime qu'on a réussi buzz
à penser ça qui fait qu'on y arrive
allez on recommence alors mes voyages
mes premières étapes le chocolat allez
vas t'en ma tante est mauvais et voilà
on aura plus qu est ce qu il est mauvais
suivants t'avais pas un bonbon mike
phillips est un imposteur à bata est
puissant que ce poste est extrêmement
dure et ya plus de battues à l'aller on
a vingt minutes pour y arriver
allez là je me sens chaud au nom je le
déteste
j'arrive pas à avoir plus de lui pour la
fin août et imsa âgées obligées espoir
là
haha excellent en ce sens que je suis là
je vais passer la journée de chou alors
nul est venu il a vu il a perdu dit
l'adage il déteste les nectars
je vais jamais y arriver à cela on a
deux vies faut se concentrer
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
oh
ensuite à l'art
que 13 minutes pour réussir à battre
sébastien c'est petit
c'est dur c'est si dur
allez de vie on peut le faire
[Musique]
je crois pas je n'y crois pas la sec la
troisième fois j'arrive à l'eau si loin
sur cette phase mais je vais manger avec
mon père et j'aurai battu d'aubameyang
jambes et on a même une meilleure note
là je vais annoncer une bonne nouvelle à
mon père ouais je serai là à 12h30 bien
à l'heure et je t'inviterai au
restaurant excellent à tout
ohlala quoi qu'il en avait rien à [ __ ]
que j'invite mais apparemment il a un
peu d'avancé ça va être fantastique de
manger après une victoire pareil j'ai su
qu'il est chaque bouchée de mon repas
n'hésitez pas à mais la vidéo si elle
vous a plu si vous trouvez que j'ai dû
ce qu'ils aimeraient voir on a combien
de % du jeu attend d'eux mdr alors mhd
mhm dhr part de 48% pour ma voix là on a
fait un petit 13% du jeu ensemble ça m'a
mis dans tous mes états mais on l'a fait
merci d'avoir regard de a très vite dans
une prochaine vidéo
[Musique]